that's cool that's amazing did you um
are there a lot of fears uh in your
culture of a lot of birth fears or there
are a lot of birth years that don't
happen in other cultures
like is there like a lot of like
you know do Chinese people do they have
like well could I ask you something yeah
and I honestly believe this I believe
that you don't know what I am
because several times in this podcast
you've referred to China
and then you look at me do you think I'm
Chinese
I don't know if you are no
be honest I don't care if you are I I
don't I know I know you I know you don't
you know
that I am okay yeah I know that you
don't care right I mean I do care but it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter to you
you're welcome around me I know you love
me regardless yeah right but it is
information that you should [__]
memorize okay we'll chill bro it's
information you should [__] memorize
because I've known you for 20 [__]
whatever dude
right it's about memorize that [__] dude
because every time I [__] see you
dude it's like China China you people in
China why do you guys eat this you know
how come you guys run this way how come
you fly you don't know how to fly or
whatever whatever you're [__] saying
is I'll I'll be happy to [__] answer
those questions but memorize what the
[__] I am
my bad dude
I'm Chinese all right
I [__] knew it dude dude why do you
do that I'm Korean are you really I'm
Korean dude I'm [__] Korean dude so
it's like God we'll just admit it get it
off your chest it's not a secret
Google it it's not a secret what I'm
saying is that every ever since I've
just ever think I'm some other [__]
Asian like when I came in here what'd
you say long long yeah you did dude
or something I'm not from Mom
I walk into you the first thing you
[__] say dude damn brother it's
insane dude memorize that [__] you're
right let me ask you some questions and
you tell me what they are okay Margaret
Cho Margaret Cho
let me see cho cho cho cho
I'm gonna say uh
uh well
I'm gonna say
Chinese no
no no
let's forget it try one more let's try
one more oh you wanna try another one
yeah
um here's a there's a complex one uh
Steve Byrne
[Music]
I would say cherish
no dude really yeah Korean too oh yeah
corrine's will surprise you then we
gotta write this down huh yeah he's
kyrish we gotta get these we gotta write
this down yeah you know the right right
no honestly Theo bro let me let's be
real dude yeah I love you dude I love
you too brother dude right what I'm
saying dude yeah it's not something you
need to write down it's something that
you could put in your brain you know how
you like memorize different kinds of
corn yeah right and like different kinds
of like condition like white people
conditions you know what I mean
yeah
asthma whatever
you can memorize
what people's at you know
ethnicity is and their nationality and
stuff Korean
exactly dude it's not hard do Koreans do
well around like what is the
who is y'all's arch nemesis in the
in the like in the Asian realm do you
guys have like a dude when you see realm
it's like you're talking about
Lord of the Rings
or some [__]
is that a realm it's just a part of the
world you know I mean realm okay yeah no
it's not okay oh sorry I'm just thinking
I'm just saying you're like you they
were like warlocks or some [__]
dude it's like I'm just saying like what
Wizards don't you [__] with no it's like
no oh we're just a part of the planet
how about this yeah don't say realm
again okay all right it's crazy but if
y'all were in a zoo let's say that don't
say that
there's two aliens in Mexico right okay
they created a zoo I think they can mix
you know what I mean different races in
a in a environment what you're saying to
me is is that aliens would go to the
human zoo and go let's go to the Chinese
section yeah
look at Epcot Center what do you think
that is oh you're right all right so
what they yeah you know what dude they
would probably have an Asian section
yeah and separate them so they would
probably put like um the Vietnamese and
cambodians and the Filipinos in one
section yeah that's fair yeah they would
put but I think they would put the
Chinese in its own section that's a lot
and they put Koreans and Japanese
aftermarket too A lot of it what do you
mean a lot of that's after market isn't
it what it was aftermarket Chinese they
make a lot of aftermarket products you
know what I'm talking about yeah yeah
yeah like if you want a replica of like
a
um rear view mirror or something like
that what would that have anything to do
with them being in a [__] group I'm
just saying that's you put them maybe in
a special section go on because of the
after part Market I'm thinking outside
oh yeah I think you're thinking too much
I am I think the Koreans and the
Japanese would have to be separated but
I don't know because time has passed
the Japanese back in the day did some
[__] up [__] yeah they invaded China
they invaded a career they invited if
the Philippines you know what I mean but
they've chilled over the years now
they're into like Hello Kitty and you
know what I mean and like relaxing relax
yeah they're relaxing they like to relax
dude they don't have a military anymore
Japan doesn't no
they don't have a military I think the
only kind of gun you can get in Japan is
a shotgun and then you have to get a
punch you have to do a bunch of classes
and [__] you want to get one but my
point is is that they've chilled over
the years that's what the two bombs did
and you know shout out to Oppenheimer
yeah so are you pro-openheimer no I'm
not pro-openheimer that was a [__] up
but I'm just saying that you know yeah
I'm sorry it happened yeah right so oh
it feels horrible it does it's horrible
there's a lot of pain in the world
you tell me dude so much pain in the
world though there's a lot of pain in
the world